bielefeld in nordrhein westfalen hier
wird das finanzamt innenstadt saniert
und zwar seit mehr als acht jahren
seitdem ist das gebäude nun schon
zugehängt und eingerüstet die 8,5
millionen euro sanierung kommt nicht in
die gänge
dabei soll hier lediglich die fassade
schön gemacht werden die bielefelder
schütteln beim blick auf die endlos
baustelle nur noch den kopf
ich habe noch nie an handwerker gewohnt
seit einem halben jahr gegenüber
es passiert nix ganz ehrlich die schon
so lange hier das medica nicht mehr
auffällt wird zeit lang ist ja gar
nichts passiert und dann hieß es wieder
es geht voran und dann wieder doch nicht
also das ist eine verschwendung von von
vielen vielen geldern im jahr 2011 lösen
sich bei dem maroden bau teile der
fassade
es besteht lebensgefahr das ganze wird
mit netzen provisorisch gesichert dann
passiert erstmal gar nichts geschlagene
fünf jahre benötigt das bau und
liegenschaftsamt nordrhein westfalen dem
das gebäude gehört für die planung erst
2016 werden ein gerüst und später ein
kran aufgebaut die bauarbeiten gehen los
geraten aber immer wieder ins stocken
oliver knauer und seine finanzamts
kollegen sitzen seit jahren auf einer
dauerbaustelle
ja das ist eben der wahnsinn seit 2011
sind wir also hinter schwedischen
gardinen so will ich das mal sagen also
wir sind seit 2011 durchgehend vernetzt
bisher wurde in acht jahren gerade mal
die alte fassade abgerissen und der
beton saniert selbst die fenster wurden
bisher noch nicht mal ausgetauscht und
momentan herrscht wieder mal
dornröschenschlaf
am anfang war die akzeptanz noch sehr
groß dass steigerte sich dann natürlich
immer mehr je länger das ganze dauert
mittlerweile sind wir einfach nur noch
fassungslos wie hier mit den
steuermitteln umgegangen
der zuständige bau- und
liegenschaftsbetrieb nrw will vor der
kamera nichts zu den kosten und der
langen bauzeit sagen
zum gegenwärtigen stillstand heißt es
schriftlich
es muss nun ein ingenieurtechnische
wiederum aufwendiges fassaden aufmaß
erstellt werden das für die
abschließende planung und alle weiteren
arbeiten zwingend erforderlich ist
aha es muss also noch mal gemessen und
wieder geplant werden aber weiter gebaut
wird hier nicht es ist natürlich eine
völlige mist planung ganz ganz klar uns
als steuerzahler kostet ist eben enorm
viel geld und ich sage mal profitieren
davon gehe ich aus dann aber auch städte
vor der nase und die bleibt wohl auch
noch ein weilchen der
fertigstellungstermin ist gerade mal
wieder verschoben wurden frühestens im
jahr 2020 sollen beim finanzamt endlich
die hüllen fallen